a problem with your dress at the Golden
Globes party let's talk about that you
had a dress malfunction what happened
that happens a lot actually
I tend to dance a little too hard so I
get really excited when I go out with my
brother cuz we we dance and and we have
a good time and and they literally my
dress was so pretty and I felt so
confident in it and it ended up
splitting right at the seams and to like
a perfect hole like on both sides it was
it was a very tight dress is what you're
saying is very tight super sexy and
literally it ripped at the seams on my
thighs because you're dancing so much
dancing i shy rating and undulating and
moving I need anyway so yes so I split
at the seams and it actually looked even
worse because it looked like I had like
Hulk legs and it just popped open so so
I decided to just go for it and rip it
all the way oh that's more like I had
like this thing in between my legs and
like my legs popped out so so the dress
you tore it but you didn't know that it
would tear that way what if you had gone
to tear it and it torn the other way
well you tweeted a picture of it I think
there you are looking upset it does look
like you've tried to save the platoon by
jumping on a grenade there but I did
send flowers to Jenny Packham the next
day thanks Ari
now let's talk about safe havens safe
haven you co-star in this movie with
Josh Duhamel yeah really really
unattractive man well you shouldn't say
that he and I have the identical torsos
he modeled his torso after mine he saw
mine in magazines I think I saw that
yeah thanks for going along with that
and he was very nice apparently you have
romantic scenes and he spoke to Ryan
Seacrest before the kissing scene to see
if it was okay well not before the
kissing just before everything cuz this
is a very romantic movie if you know
anything about Nicholas Sparks there are
some bedroom scenes so anyways we were
at the gym and what this was in south
fort North Carolina
where we were shooting and they ran into
each other and Josh just felt the need
to be like everything is cool like I
know this is that kind of movie but you
don't have to worry and then Brian was
like I mean yeah that's cool dude like
why are you telling me this this is
really awkward yeah I just want to drink
some kelp and get out of here
we have a clip here from safe haven
anything we need to know about this
scene uh yeah this is really fun scene
I painted my floors yellow because of
Josh Duhamel daughter in the movie she
she recommended that color that's right
he's lost his wife he's got kids you two
come together and what signal this clip
from safe haven
oh I forgot to ask how'd your your force
turn out you want to see I wasn't too
sure what the yellow but it looks pretty
good yeah thanks to your primer and
Lexi's Tina I could have been killed
[Applause]